bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors finalement on donald
trump accélère le retrait des militaires
américains en afghanistan
pas tout à fait il s'agit de lire
attentivement le tweet du président le
tweet du président est au conditionnel
we should a donc ça c'est vraiment un
élément important à garder présent à
l'esprit à car il ya un cadre politique
n'est ce pas à cet accord entre
l'afghanistan les talibans et les états
unis à qui est du mois de février est
donc dans cet accord il ya les questions
d'un retrait définitif en milieu de
l'année 2021
donc s'il y a maintenant un nouvelle
indication du président au conditionnel
il faut peut-être mettre en en exergue
le fait qu'il y ait des élections dans
quelques petites semaines aux états unis
et qu'il a à dans les sondages un retard
certain a vis-à-vis de son que de son
adversaire et un retard certain dans les
votes envisagée dans les sondages des
soldats américains
et justement est ce que serait son
retrait que dans l'antre up entend
vouloir accélérer est ce que ça pourrait
être remis en question si jamais joe
biden était lui le coprah avec le
l'accord qui est signée donc depuis
février avec les talibans et l'état
afghan spécifie donc mis 2021 donc c'est
un engagement des états unis et le futur
président des états unis bien sûr suivra
les lignes de cet accord puisqu'il a été
signé par le président des états unis
alors cet accord dont vous me parliez en
signant en février à 2019 prévoit que
les talibans négoce
avec les autorités de kaboul sont nés ou
au niveau de ces négociations là et bien
les négociations a été poursuivie
maintenant à ado a à nouveau les
américains sont aussi présents et donc
essaye d'harmoniser les points de vue
entre les différentes parties donc
talibans et le gouvernement officiel et
élus de l'afghanistan
donc il y à une progression il ya une
proposition de la part du président
afghan à demandant aux talibans est bien
de reconnaître d'établir un
cessez-le-feu définitif parce que il n'y
a absolument rien à faire il n'aura
absolument les talibans rien à craindre
les attentats ne sont pas contre eux
c'est eux qui les formant et est ce que
l'afghanistan est prêt pour ce retrait
est ce que l'armée afghane est préparée
prêtes à assurer seules la sécurité du
pays bien écoutez c'est un défi un défi
pour la population afghane c'est un défi
pour l'armée elle a été préparée à cela
depuis de nombreuses années à la fois
par les etats-unis aussi par de
nombreuses équipes militaires
européennes deux ans cadre donc de la
présence de l'otan en afghanistan dont
qu'ils il y à un matériel substantielle
inquiets sur place donc cet élément-là
plus un accord politique devrait
permettre effectivement à l'armée
afghane de maintenir une sécurité et une
paix à l'intérieur du territoire
concrètement qu'ont fait les américains
depuis le déploiement de leurs troupes
en afghanistan
ils ont entre autres permis aux jeunes
filles d'aller à l'école
ils ont entre autres permis à aux
afghans de voter et de choisir librement
leurs institutions et leurs dirigeants
ils ont insufflé à un nombre substantiel
de centaines de milliards dans
l'économie afghane
aussi bien dans l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles que en afgha en
infrastructures donc il y a un apport il
ya malheureusement bien sûr d
moore nombreux mais qui le plus souvent
ne sont pas causés par la présence
américaine mais plutôt par les attentats
et a menée par les talibans vous êtes
optimiste pour la suite en tout cas pour
l'afghanistan
il le faut et je pense qu'il le voulait
il ya peut-être des parallèles à faire
il y a maintenant dans quelques mois dix
ans de présence militaire internationale
en syrie dans voyez vous les choses sont
toujours très très compliqué il faut
intégrer le temps et peut-être donc à
avoir le courage de mettre en place de
nouveaux dispositifs l'art vestiaires
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
directes sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes du chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
merci